thank you very much all of our patreons  especially our defibrillators and our  Heimlich maneuver because today is the  first day in the history of JK news I  think ever where I'm presenting an  article Wow  and the reason why I don't do these is I  never studied I [ __ ] you not right  before this camera started I opened this  I was prepped yesterday and I decided to  put it off like it is a midterm  assignment but we have the lovely Stacey  here who is going to read I studied it  when I was little I used to practice  he's someone studied at that yeah yeah  so in diarrhea dump use submitted by  Anais when you got a bucket of hot area  was randomly poured on a woman by a bro  by a homeless man my biggest [ __ ]  nightmare oh I Nev a tassel was parked  in Hollywood after having a pleasant  evening with friends at an authentic  Thai restaurant